The internet supports heterogeneity through the
TCP/IP protocol stack. TCP/IP was designed as
a monolithic transport, where TCP provided flow
control and reliable delivery, and IP provided
universal forwarding. Now it became clear
that not every application needed reliable in
order delivery. For example, streaming voice and
video. Often perform well, even if not
every packet is delivered. And the domain
name system, which converts domain names to
IP addresses, often also doesn't need completely
reliable in order delivery. Fortunately, the narrow
waste of IP allowed the proliferation of
many different transport protocols, not just TCP.
The second way that the internet's design
accomodates Hetergeneity is through a best-effort service
model, whereby the network can lose packets, deliver them out of order, and
doesn't really provide any quality guarantees.
It also doesn't provide information about failures,
performance, et cetera. On the plus side, this makes for a simple design,
but it also makes certain kinds
of debugging and network management more difficult.